and as your striker gunvolt you charge
through a series of missions in the
order of your choosing contending with
pitfalls in Robo fodder until you engage
in a boss battle confined to a single
screen arena and if you're successful
you're rewarded with a new type of gun
so yes it shares a few things in common
with Mega Man but what I've just
described is in effect and armature a
skeleton in the game that's designed
around it performs its own identity
through experimental mechanics and an
electric eye catching presentation it's
a fast-paced ride in a fantastic
side-scrolling action game and although
the main mission path isn't difficult to
finish completing the breadth of gun
bolts optional trials and seeing
everything through to the end well
challenge and please even the most
hardened veteran looking for a megaman
like experience
given its action-oriented roots and then
it's developed by a team with 12 years
of Megaman games under its belt it's not
surprising that a gun is central to the
action and gun bolt but it's a notably
unusual model rather than firing bullets
in a traditional sense your sidearm
shoots metallic tags that allow the
lightning from gunvault spherical flash
field to arc across the screen and
inflict damage the flash field extends
from your body in a generous ring but
will only inflict minimal damage to an
enemy that hasn't been tagged activating
it in midair will slow your descent for
a short period of time but given that
you quickly run out of fuel refer to as
ep you can't keep it activated
indefinitely deplete your reserves and
you'll overheat
which delays the amount of time before
the auto recharge effect kicks in the
flow of action in gun volt deviates from
your traditional run and gun
side-scroller due to this system which
is a pleasant surprise given that you
still for the most part run to the right
while firing a pistol mastering the art
of quickly and cleanly soaring through
missions while managing your EP levels
is a dance that takes time to master do
well and you'll earn the chance to
unlock raw materials that are used to
synthesize new equipment altering gun
vaults movement abilities and EP
expenditure though you earn a new type
of gun for each boss you defeat they
merely introduce new trajectories for
your tagged bullets so the emphasis on
weaponry compared to something like
Megaman is downplayed quite a bit
you're better off focusing on improving
the speed of your game and the
destructiveness of your flash field to
string together combos and level up
faster the sooner you do the sooner you
unlock powerful limited use offensive
and recovery skills gun vault can be
challenging at times but these moments
are limited to endgame boss battles and
optional skill trials the latter of
which are necessary for obtaining some
of the harder to find sympathy riyals
some early trials are a walk in the park
but the challenges that follow are
incredibly demanding and one slip-up can
make the difference between a successful
or failed attempt
playing with the equipment and crafting
system can make things easier but you
quickly find that completing challenges
more than the main mission is the
ultimate sign of mastering gunvault
abilities it's enjoyable to be able to
breeze through the main game while
learning how to wield gun bolts
abilities with newfound confidence but
considering that most levels can be
completed in about 10 minutes and there
are just over ten to explore it's also a
bit deflating when the game runs out of
new things to see the optional
challenges and the hunt for hidden items
that motivate you to return time and
again are worthwhile endeavors that will
encourage you to play for a few
additional hours but you're still
repeatedly retracing the same path and
this is gunvault only downfall that's
not to say you won't find yourself going
back in for just one more run because
you will it's just that fun to play but
as exciting a fresh take on the core
Megaman formula ultimately comes to an
end sooner than it deserves